hello Conan O'Brien here welcome to
Conan O'Brien needs a friend and uh I
feel like I have two friends with me
right now Sonam obsessian and I believe
it's Matt Matthew Matt Gourley and uh I
think we're Pals we have a good flow
people like the way that uh we work
together that's weird that yeah people
like our kind of relationship even
though I don't think we do
I don't think that's important yeah the
chef doesn't have to love what he's
making I see you know and um he doesn't
you probably shouldn't yeah yeah why
would he make something he doesn't like
that doesn't make sense what a terrible
shot what are we doing here here you go
some more I make
what you're talking about I think this
is a lovely eclair oh no
I hate it
why do you hate it so much
she's childhood struck by lightning
everything tastes like to me why
did you become a chef
I like the Hat
it's fun to wear it it's called a took
all right
is
really you got into this all food that
you ingest tastes like excrement to you
because you were struck by liking his
child
so you serve it and I hate it
even watching you eat it makes me sick
but you stayed in it because of the took
why are you going over this again and
again we established everything it seems
like bad improv trick
not at all I'm just trying to say that
you tasted things and they hey we've
gone through it why do you repeat so
much well it turns out I was struck by
lightning and uh as a child and so I
tend to over set things up that's what I
do you and I could be friends both
struck by lightning
you set things up right I tend to set
things up now just to summarize you were
hit by lightning oh I'm gonna
kill you
and then
it made you go over things too much when
you're doing a podcast is that right
[Laughter]
uh man I don't know where that one
started but I think we had a good time
we had a good journey oh man we learned
a lot I think about ourselves and about
I learned you did you can do a French
accent a German accent and an Italian
accent all at the scene and they all
sound end up sounding Russian yeah
by the way Nixon that guy was from
Croatia oh yeah okay all right yeah okay
yeah so anyway I just wanted to clear
the air on that yeah you know I just why
Croatia popped into my head huh I I took
uh uh you know a uber today uh to get
here and I um my I I'm a guy who talks
to the driver I always like to I'm one
of those people I don't know where you
guys follow me I choose no conversation
on you do you really do that yeah I do I
I just I'm not good at small talk I
don't mean that to be anti-social right
it's okay sleep okay and what about you
so I do both so I'm either not talking
at all or he's coming up into my
apartment checking out the sofa I'm
trying to get rid of and that's a true
story that's a true story you gotta have
boundaries you're right you know whether
you're on a cross-country drive or on
your daily commute time in the car is
perfect for listening to podcasts like I
don't know this one
T-Mobile covers more highway miles with
5G than anyone their Network helps keep
you connected to all your favorite
podcasts when you're out and about I
gotta tell you I like to road trip
sometimes I do too and I I have T-Mobile
and I ca I can honestly say there's
coverage that's important like there's
been times in my life where I'm out on
the road driving around and uh
especially on those family trips you're
out in the desert you want to make sure
you have that coverage yeah what if you
get like your car breaks down and you're
just there sitting there like a chump
yeah no coverage yeah not this guy I've
got T-Mobile got 5G find out more at
t-mobile.com Cy that's
s-e-e-w-h-y I'm gonna tell you this I do
not I've seen the the little switch that
says no uh that you can tap that says no
conversation this is me to be completely
honest I'm afraid that if I hit that
they're going to think oh I'm driving us
like a stuck up snob yeah and so I will
never hit that and then I go too far the
other way where they hit it on you trust
me I think some of these people would
because I say I mean this guy today I
could tell he was from you know and I
said well where are you from and a lot
of times this is actually works out
nicely because uh there are many drivers
who are Armenian yeah and then we chat
and they know that I've been to Armenia
with you and we have like a really good
conversation uh and they like that I
know like three words
um and uh English in English but then uh
today the guy was from Croatia and we
were just talking back and forth and I
got his whole story like his whole life
story it was actually pretty fascinating
and so uh I got out of the car and I
felt like oh good I I really I really
got to know that guy I hope he liked it
too you made a friend he had no idea who
I was
um he was asking me what I do and I just
said I just work in television
um I think he thinks I'm a TV repairman
yeah I fixed flat screens but we had a
it was it was really nice I don't know
that's cool you made a new friend no I
don't I think I think that's it oh I
think that's it well at least it was
pleasant because I think you have to be
too if you're not a pleasant person that
could like people and if someone
recognizes you then well this is
something I I very envious of are the
people who have made their reputation
and we've you know like a Jack Nicholson
or Harrison Ford or like people who are
you know these big stars obviously in
this whole other caliber than anything I
would ever be where if you went up to
them and said hey man and they said
off
you'd say wow yeah yeah that's so cool
I'm I'm not that person if someone came
up to me and I went he's better off
uh it's like you're an
we're dancing around like an idiot on TV
all those years you acting all friendly
you're a sham and then they would just
start hitting me with a two by four
that's true that's true yeah I know but
that's I don't I mean you can't be that
guy you can't be like so I don't I don't
know I don't worry no no I don't I don't
have that uh incredible you know
so I'm not self-possessed like that and
I also those are people that are larger
than life you see them on the screen and
they're Larger than Life I managed to be
much smaller in life because people have
seen me on small televisions well and
you need people to like you yeah you
mean that oh like I need a friend yes
yeah oh yeah I have a breakthrough here
yeah well I think they could like punch
someone in the face and people would be
like oh my God he punched me in the face
and then with you they'd just sue you
well also they'd have to feel it first I
didn't say like was that a cool breeze I
just gave you a a chop to the jaw
I just I just played a little chin music
with uh
with my right hook
well I didn't really oh so you struck me
yes I did oh I thought a I thought a
very old butterfly had a stroke and then
a cool wind blew it against my cheek
but if you struck me I'm suing you now
all right I'll pay up I don't think that
would go too well uh but anyway were you
signaling me that I should get on with
it yeah okay it was awkward because then
I just looked at you and you didn't
signal me I did I held up the rap sign I
know but I didn't I saw something in my
peripheral vision
and this is a note to all my would-be
attackers
I think I'm losing my peripheral vision
so ninjas time to get me
uh but I saw a little Flash oh I saw I
saw a finger a middle finger go up for I
think for half a second I was just
itching my eye okay well okay again
peripheral vision's starting to go you
thought now that your peripheral
vision's going away now ninjas can
attack you as in before yeah you had it
yeah I like ninjas are gonna be fine
with a full frontal assault please I
think first of all I think there's a
whole many many many different sections
of the Assassin League uh that have been
trying to get me for years but they I
have legendary peripheral vision so the
ninjas have just been waiting around
smoking cigarettes
playing Mahjong waiting ninjas don't
smoke cigarettes yes they do oh they're
such Chainsmokers they cut out little
holes in the ninja mask they puff away
well now they do e-cigarettes those ones
that smell like bubble gum
like do I smell bubble gum oh look
ninjas waiting for Conan
to lose his peripheral vision and
reading Us magazine they broke up they
sure did
oh they seem like such a good couple Hey
I just heard that from an eye doctor
that Conan's losing his peripheral
vision everyone gets your throwing stars
it's time